le go sport
deschamps est une musique qui exprime
encore la douleur et la résilience des
noirs aux états unis une souffrance que
seuls les afro américains peuvent
comprendre des rythmes qui leur ont
permis de traverser le pays le long du
fleuve mississippi les églises des états
du sud sont un des derniers endroits où
blanc et noir ne se mêle pas la messe le
dimanche incarne encore les divisions
raciales de l'époque de la ségrégation
dans ses champs de coton que nous
traversons dans le delta du mississippi
les esclaves noirs chanter le gospel des
champs de désespoir qui ont mené aux
blues la chanteuse nanette workman nous
accompagne sur la route du blues et nous
amène à crocs dell ou le blues est née
la nette a grandi dans l'état du
mississipi ses racines musicales sont
ici c'est vraiment un os dans la soupe
de la musique ici dans cette petite
ville près du fleuve mississippi vivent
encore les meilleurs bluesmen james
johnson alias super hot chicken fabrique
lui même ses guitares avec lesquels il
joue du blues
partout dans le monde pour lui cette
musique a été un moteur de changement
pour les afro américains
ce soir là soupire chikane joue au bar
grenoble
la mecque du blues propriété de l'acteur
morgan freeman et du maire de la ville
vers la quête
nous sommes en plein festival de blues à
clarksdale
à une certaine époque
impossible pour un blanc d'entrée dans
un bar blues à clarksdale ville à
majorité noire
no le maire de clarksdale a vécu la
ségrégation des années 50 et 60
aujourd'hui dit-il blancs et noirs se
côtoient un peu plus mais blanc et noir
sont toujours prisonniers de lui au
passé raciale voilà cinq ans boca 6 n'a
pris qu'un but de toute la musique du
monde ne ramènera pas l'harmonie totale
le long du mississippi
la respecte beaucoup d'eau va couler
encore sous les ponts avant que pleins
et noir ne vibrent au même diapason